rihanna and asap rocky are expecting
their first baby together and the two
couldn't be more excited for parenthood
she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents a source tells e.t that the
couple is so happy about the pregnancy
quote rihanna has always wanted to be a
mother and have children she thinks asap
is going to be the best dad and asap he
knows it the new york native told gq
last may that he'll be quote an
incredible remarkably overall amazing
dad that would have a very fly child i'm
honestly truly blessed real you know
riri and asap debuted the grammy winners
baby bump in this glamorous photo shoot
shot in the rapper's hometown of harlem
last saturday
that's the singer covered in colorful
jewels sporting a pink chanel vintage
coat bringing her fashion a game per
usual it was fun it turns out the rapper
has been riri's rock throughout the
pregnancy our source says quote asap has
been tending to all of brianna's needs
and they are really enjoying this moment
together as a couple rihanna and asap
have such a strong bond and they can't
wait to experience parenthood together i
couldn't tell you how happy i am and
it's no surprise the two are so in sync
the pregnancy news comes just days after
a source told et that riri and asap are
inseparable
[Music]
the source explains the pair took some
time to relax unwind and reconnect after
a very busy fall
now that things have slowed down their
relationship is in a good place
and supporting each other comes
naturally it's something asap opened up
to e.t about at the premiere of his
documentary stockholm syndrome it was
important having that support in real
life you know and i think it just shows
it will reveal in the dock it's just how
it is in real life but even before they
decided to have a kid together asap and
rihanna already considered themselves a
family
[Music]
another source told et on monday the
couple feels very blessed to welcome a
little one which only makes their
connection stronger quote they enjoyed
keeping the pregnancy a secret for as
long as they could but they're thrilled
to be able to share the news with their
fans
[Music]